hey 42 here in the east of America there
exists a tiny and terrifying blood
sucking creature and no it's not Rupert
Murdoch it's called the Lone Star tick
if this tiny insect were to bite you it
can cause you to become permanently
allergic to red meat and what a terrible
tragedy that will be this tick injects
your blood with the type of meat sugar
which triggers antibodies within your
immune system and permanently
reconfigures them to react whenever red
meat deliciously finds its way into your
body again in the future after just one
bite from this tick you could find
yourself having an anaphylactic shock
the next time you so much as tediously
liquor tempting Filat of beefy
perfection or of a red meat every year
in America over 5,000 people develop
such a cruel allergy from this tiny
vegan terrorists come to think of it I'm
quite surprised that vegans haven't yet
weaponized these ticks there is an
epidemic happening allergies are getting
more severe and far more common in the
US and UK allergies among children have
increased by over 100 percent in the
past ten years and hospital admissions
for allergic reactions have increased by
over five hundred percent over the last
twenty years what's going on here and is
this exponentially growing trend ever
going to stop or in 100 years time as
the entire human race going to be
destitute to a lifetime of porridge and
dust which would be terrible because
dust is not as tasty as steak that's a
fact
allergies are an astonishingly strange
and complex phenomenon and modern
science still doesn't fully grasp the
true nature of them when a victim comes
across a mere trace of an allergen they
can suffer horrendous even fatal
consequences anaphylaxis can cause
vomiting diarrhea hives rashes swelling
anxiety confusion headaches loss of
breath and sometimes death but the
cruelly ironic thing about allergic
reactions is that the symptoms are
caused entirely by our own mind just
because you have an allergy to shellfish
it doesn't suddenly make shellfish
inherently poisonous
your immune system has learned to reject
that particular food viewing it as an
invader and so your body does everything
it can to reject what it thinks is an
unwelcomed guest from your body however
that measures your immune system takes
can sometimes be so severe that there
are shocking consequences
a sobering reminder of how we are always
at the mercy of our own bodies and minds
the range of allergies is also growing
and you won't believe what some people
are genuinely allergic to aquagenic
urticaria is an allergy to water yes you
heard me water it's genuine and it
affects about one in every two hundred
and thirty million people imagine your
insides burning with an intense and
unrelenting rage every time you swallow
a mouthful of pure h2o
rain feels like acid depressingly and
ironically so does your own sweat taking
a bath is akin to submerging oneself in
Bleach then there's cold urticaria an
allergy to cold weather and I'm not just
talking about when the temperature drops
by two degrees and you freak out like a
beached halibut sufferers of this
bizarre ailment come out in hives rashes
and burning skin whenever the
temperature drops by just a few degrees
or when they touch or drink cold liquids
cold temperatures cause those afflicted
to undergo a severe histamine reaction
which can sometimes lead to fainting and
in some rare cases death just the
thought of having such a horrendous
allergy gives me the shivers what have I
told you but women can be allergic to
their own mood swings now before you put
out a Lonely Hearts ad with this highly
specific requirement
it's no joke it's actually a rather
severe ailment probably one of the
weirdest allergens is that of an allergy
to female hormones or autoimmune
progesterone dermatitis is a severe
allergy that affects some women during
their menstrual cycle during the second
half of the cycle progesterone levels in
the body begin to rise and the tiny
percentage of women have a histamine
reaction
- this hormone the hormone that their
own body is producing during this time
each month the sufferers skin can become
red itchy puffy and wholly covered in
lesions and blisters and one's face may
be covered in hives the fact that such
severe symptoms can be caused by a
chemical reaction within our own body
without any outside influence whatsoever
is a macabre testament to the power of
our brains and their havoc our own body
can wreak upon itself food allergy rates
have experienced a sharp rise across the
globe over the past two decades
especially in children so what's going
on here is the cause GMOs MSG h2o THC
KFC scientists still aren't entirely
sure why there has been such a vast
increase in in tolerances but a leading
theory is called hygiene theory
for at least the past 40 years in all
developed countries we have been living
a more sanitary lifestyle and of each
passing decade our honed public spaces
and ourselves have become increasingly
sterile antibacterial sprays and soaps
have become our best friends and secret
worst enemies because many scientists
now believe that this obsessive
cleanliness could be contributing to the
rapid increase in food allergies when
you deprive your immune system of
malicious bacteria to fight off it
doesn't get the practice that is
required to develop sufficient defenses
against a wide range of bacteria we now
enjoy such hygienic lifestyles on a day
to day basis that our immune systems
have become so deficient they are
mistaking harmless substances such as
nuts shellfish and other allergens as
malicious invaders that should be
ejected from our bodies by any means
possible the FDA even now thinks that
hygiene theory has a lot of weight to it
because it has recently been
investigating it as a cause of ologies
so we could essentially be giving
ourselves these allergies
one fact that makes this theory so
plausible is that research has found
that kids who grew up on a farm or spend
a lot of time in the countryside
are considerably less likely to develop
allergies or asthma throughout their
lifetime whereas children who grow up in
an urban environment are many times more
likely to have in tolerances or develop
breathing issues scientists believe this
is due to a specific type of dust that
is only found in the countryside and in
higher densities on farms this dust has
been proven to trigger a strong immune
reaction therefore improving our immune
system and strengthening its barriers
and of course a generally stronger
immune system means fewer allergies but
exposure to these natural bacteria has
to happen during childhood whilst our
immune system is still developing some
scientists are now working to
concentrate the irritants found within
the farm dust into a vaporizer which
could be given to urban children when
they're young working as a kind of
vaccine against allergens and asthma but
until it arrives on the scene I highly
recommend taking your children to your
nearest farm and rubbing their face in
manure but you may not have to do that
because according to recent studies
there may be a better way to prevent
your kids from inflating like a Zeppelin
when they think about peanuts in 2012 a
group of European researchers conducted
the most extensive survey on eating
habits in history
they studied 320,000 adolescents and
180,000 children in 51 countries the
study was named the International study
of asthma and allergies in childhood my
Cullen's have named it better myself
what the study concluded was that eating
fast food or heavily processed foods
three or more times a week increases a
child's risk of developing an allergy or
asthma by 39 percent
conversely eating fruit was found to
have the complete opposite effect eating
fruit three or more times per week was
found to decrease the likelihood of
developing the aforementioned ailments
by 11 percent following this extensive
study and many others since it has been
popularly theorized that our chance of
developing a severe food allergy is
directly relate
channel to the diversity of food we eat
as children enjoying a whole range of
food from all around the world at an
early age whilst we are still developing
permanently teaches our immune system
that these foods and similar foods are
not harmful to our bodies whereas if we
spend our childhood avoiding all kinds
of sea life and shellfish then at the
age of 30 we try an oyster for the very
first time our immune system is going to
freak out like any on crack because it
literally has no frame of reference as
to what strange new substances and
compounds just entered our body so it
does what it does best everything it can
to reject it in the worst case that
includes initiating anaphylaxis which is
like that secret plan in an ominous
manila envelope it keeps for when all
else seems hopeless but in reality what
you just ate is not harmful at all
however your immune system doesn't know
that because it's the first time it has
ever encountered it or anything remotely
similar and that is why ladies and
gentlemen there is a special place
reserved in hell for parents who raise
their children are nothing more than a
variety of shaped and frozen potato goo
the alarming 500% increase analogies
over the past 20 years that I mentioned
earlier is based on an increase in
doctor diagnosed allergies people whose
ailments are as real as their cruel
symptoms but there's another sake layer
of allergy sufferers that sits on top of
that statistic like a disappointingly
damp squib and it's a far larger group
of miscreants the fakers those whose
allergies are about as genuine as a
fortune cookie I am of course referring
to those people we've all met whose
claims of allergies or intolerances seem
as flaky as two delicious pastries they
refuse to eat
[Music]
one of the most pertinent examples is
gluten sensitivity celiac disease is
absolutely unquestionably real yet
despite only around 1% of the population
having celiac disease over ten times
that many people now claim to be either
allergic or intolerant to gluten weight
is often tell of stories on websites and
blogs of customers requesting an
entirely gluten-free meal causing the
kitchen to go to great lengths to avoid
the nearest trace of wheat and gluten
from touching their food and then when
the dessert comes they reach over with
their treacherous cutlery and wolfed out
a spoonful of their friends gluten
ridden apple pie with unbridled
impertinence whilst from the wings the
weight and kitchen staff scoff and grind
their teeth at the guiltless impostor
before them sales of gluten-free
products have risen by 15% over the past
five years and it is now a multi-billion
pound industry worldwide in America one
in five people now avoid gluten entirely
and when asked one-third of Americans
said they would ideally like to avoid
gluten you just know that something
truly disturbing is going on when
Americans and the rest of the world for
that matter want to voluntarily give up
doughnuts when there is no medical
reason for them to be doing so
I'm sure that everyone watching knows at
least one person he woke up one morning
recently and suddenly decided that
gluten is now the cause of all our
worldly issues and is now in fact
created by lucifer whether you've
noticed it or not over the past five to
ten years going gluten-free has become a
fad trend craze neurosis whatever you
want to call it many have gone
gluten-free after hearing from some
celebrity that is good for weight loss
or because Pam from work claims to have
shed 90% of her body weight in a week
well done Pam but there are absolutely
no credible studies at back up any of
the claims that going gluten-free aids
weight loss ironically and somewhat
humorously there was a study in 2006
that followed 371 people on a
gluten-free diet the result was that
after two years on the diet 82 percent
of them had gained weight another study
with children found that after 12 months
of a completely gluten-free diet the
percentage of overweight children had
doubled this weight gain has been mostly
attributed to the fact that the majority
of gluten-free options available in
shops and cafes contain more fats and
more sugar than their regular gluttonous
counterparts gluten-free items also
contain none of the only healthy
components of a lot of bread and doughy
items the fiber were hold on there
though these poor victims actually
experienced physical symptoms when
eating gluten surely gluten sensitivity
is a real thing well a science is still
not certain about the answer to that one
but there have been a multitude of new
studies in very recent years that seem
to suggest gluten sensitivity may not
actually exist please bear in mind I'm
only echoing what these studies have
concluded a 2013 study for example
published in the Journal of
Gastroenterology concluded that there
was no evidence to link gluten to the
symptoms that the test participants
claimed to have experienced during the
study test participants were cycled
through three different diets high
gluten low
and no gluten the participants didn't
know which diet they were on at any one
time afterwards though all test
participants at all times during the
study claimed to experience symptoms
such as pain bloating nausea and gas
even whilst they were on a no gluten
diet
Peter Gibson who ran the experiment
believes the test participants were
experiencing what's called a nocebo
effect because these self-diagnose
gluten intolerance test subjects were
expecting to feel symptoms at some point
during the experiment their brains hence
manifested the symptoms anyway
regardless of their actual gluten intake
likewise another study in 2017 found no
evidence to link gluten or wheat to any
symptoms that test participants claimed
to experience when eating gluten it did
however suggest that song but by no
means all people who claimed to be
gluten intolerant may actually be
sensitive to something else entirely
FODMAPs FODMAPs are a group of
carbohydrates that can cause bloating
gas and stomach pain in some people
FODMAPs can be found in a whole array of
foods including some grains asparagus
onions garlic mushrooms and leek gluten
sensitivity aside on a more general
scope Portsmouth University recently
conducted research which concluded that
after 20% of British people and a
whopping 30% of Americans who believe
they have a food allergy or intolerance
of some kind only 2% of them could
actually be medically diagnosed as
having said allergy or intolerance this
means that there are many millions of
people out there falsely claiming that
eating a particular food will make them
ill why is this there are two leading
theories to why so many people even
knowingly or unknowingly fake analogy
the first reason is just that it feels
easier to simply say I'm allergic to
that rather than admitting you just
don't like the taste of that particular
food if you just refuse to eat something
claiming you're allergic to it
makes you sound less picky and people
are more likely to sympathize with you
which leads me on to the second theory
psychologists have been quite interested
in this whole fake allergy phenomenon
recently due to the fact that it's
becoming more popular than having common
sense many such psychologists believe
that by creating strict boundaries for
ourselves surrounding what we can and
can't eat
we provide order in our lives people who
have otherwise highly disordered lives
fineness to be a huge relief in the past
Yoda was created for us because there
were religious or governmental laws
about what foods and drinks we were
permitted or not permitted to eat at
certain times on certain days of the
week even more stringently so during
times of Russia some people who may have
a chaotic disordered or otherwise
stressful lifestyle actually find this
kind of limitation comforting
psychologists also put forward the
hypothesis that creating fake allergies
or intolerances for ourselves makes us
feel like a special little button ok
they may not have used that exact
wording humans have an innate desire
which stems from childhood to feel
unique and special today we live in a
highly entitled society where the
younger generation my generation and the
generation below me have grown up being
told that they can have anything but do
anything they want to do because they
are special but when the day comes when
they realize that they aren't actually
any more special than the millions of
other people around them they decide to
make themselves special whether that's
choosing to be a vegan going gluten free
or deciding that you're now allergic to
any foods that ends with the letter R
this instantaneously forces everyone
they know when those they encounter when
dining out to fuss over them pay more
attention to them than the other diners
at the table and treat them like the
special little mushroom that they
believe they are but these self-diagnose
confidence boost in the form of phony
allergies are laden with irony and this
is why the mind is an exceedingly
powerful entity if your brain wants to
make
feel ill even when you're not it can do
so at the drop of a hat and by
continually saying that you are allergic
to a particular food gluten or lactose
intolerance you can actually give
yourself a kind of placebo effect
whereby you do start to feel and
experience genuine symptoms when you eat
said foods just like believing that
you're a wizard you can actually make
yourself allergic to a specific food
group if you believe it strongly enough
this works on an entirely mental level
you are not creating analogy for
yourself your brain is just manifesting
the symptoms for you in a very real and
tangible way but the funny thing is if
you do stop eating a certain food or
group of foods for many years your
immune system will actually forget how
to counteract any potential allergens
within that food given enough time and
then several years down the line when it
Rhian counters it it freaks out like a
Mormon in a brothel and yes you can
eventually make yourself genuinely
allergic to something just by cutting it
out of your diet for a prolonged period
of time but is there anything wrong with
this if people want to self-diagnose to
gain recognition and eventually give
themselves food intolerances is it a
problem
maybe not for that person but for
restaurants and for genuine allergy
sufferers it causes more problems than
you probably realize you see when
someone tells a waiter that they have an
allergy or even just an intolerance they
are forced by various laws regulations
and food standards agencies to take that
extremely seriously they don't know you
and they certainly don't know how severe
your intolerance is or whether it
actually exists so naturally and frankly
any kitchen worth their salt must assume
that even a trace of that food substance
within your meal could potentially kill
you in a decent restaurant this means
taking very special precautions for that
dine such as cleaning and using a
separate part of the kitchen different
organs and fryers specifically for
cooking that meal washing and using
different knives utensils chopping
boards and pans
and this level of obsession over tiny
details is absolutely necessary because
many people with genuine allergies could
go into anaphylaxis if only a few
particles of the allergen are somewhere
on or near their plate of food but when
chefs go through all these steps to
proudly protect their most vulnerable
diners and then they found out that most
of their patrons who claim to be
so-called allergy sufferers are in fact
fakers or at the very least delusional
about their own intolerance it creates
animosity between the diners and the
kitchen and you could argue that if
you're paying for the meal and the
chef's would bend over backwards to
accommodate your every need no matter
how genuine those needs are but the more
this trend of fad diets increases such
as gluten intolerance and veganism then
the more chefs everywhere are going to
stop taking the needs of their diners so
seriously if you don't believe this is
happening then take this one small
example from the white mousse cafe in
Dublin who recently posted on their
Facebook page guests who demand
gluten-free food are required to produce
a doctor's note which states that you
suffer from celiac disease guests
following a gluten free fad who don't
even know what gluten is can cup the
[ __ ] on and eat regular food like
everyone else mo chefs have absolutely
no problem catering for genuine
sufferers but when they are repeatedly
tested night after night by disingenuous
people following empty food trends it
creates a scenario of the boy who cried
wolf and one day a diner with a severe
food allergy is going to walk through
the doors of a restaurant and the chefs
are going to disbelieve their allergy
and the standards may slip and the diner
may be given contaminated food ending in
a tragic fatality I'm not being dramatic
such occurrences have happened in recent
years and are only on the rise that's
why making up a food allergy or
diagnosing oneself based on little to no
evidence other than information that day
from the gym told you is most definitely
damaging to real sufferers
and ultimately selfish thanks for
watching
[Music]